Finding Dory floats onto the big screen this
summer and sees the return of Pixar's plucky
clownfish Nemo and our favourite funny and
forgetful blue tang Dory.
In this sequel to Finding Nemo, Dory's memory
is triggered by a stingray migration and she
sets off on a quest to find her family with
the help of Marlin and Nemo.
Finding Dory promises to explore a new chapter
in Nemo's ocean world, so let's take a look
at the new and returning characters we can
look forward to meeting in the movie.
First up is Destiny, a whale shark, voiced
by Kaitlin Olson, star of It's Always Sunny
In Philadelphia.
Destiny has difficulty swimming straight due
to poor eyesight, and realising there's something
familiar about Dory, she befriends the blue
tang when she visits the Marine Life Institute.
Whale sharks are the largest fish in the sea
and Destiny herself is not only very big-hearted
but also speaks whale.
Which is very handy, because at the Marine
Life Institute, Destiny is friendly with Bailey,
a beluga whale, although they do like to poke
fun at each other, with Bailey calling Destiny
a whale, rather than a shark, and Destiny
making fun of Bailey's huge head.
Bailey thinks his biological sonar skills
don't work properly, although the Institute's
doctors don't seem to think there's anything
really wrong with him.
Bailey is voiced by Modern Family star Ty
Burrell.
Speaking of Modern Family, Ed O'Neill, Ty
Burell's co-star from the hit comedy series,
voices Hank the octopus, who is strictly just
a septopus, as he's only got seven tentacles.
Hank is adept at camouflage and escaping from
tricky situations, and he's the first to greet
Dory at the Marine Life Institute, but he's
only willing to help her in return for "a
ticket on a transport truck to a cozy Cleveland
facility where he'll be able to enjoy a peaceful
life of solitude."
In Finding Dory, Marlin and Nemo come across
a pair of snoozing sea lions called Fluke
and Rudder just outside the Marine Life Institute.
They're voiced by British actors Idris Elba
and Dominic West who worked together on the
critically acclaimed crime drama series The
Wire.
Director Andrew Stanton has said he wanted
Fluke and Rudder to sound like British gangster-style
talking sea lions.
When Nemo and Marlin encounter them, they're
resting on a sought-after rock and don't enjoy
having their nap disturbed, although their
"bark is far worse than their bite."
Dory's mother Jenny is voiced by Annie Hall
star Diane Keaton and her father Charlie is
played by American Pie's Eugene Levy.
Dory's parents don't suffer from quite the
same memory loss as Dory.
Jenny is upbeat and a little flighty, but
she loves Dory dearly and wants to be a good
role model for her.
Charlie likes to have fun, although his jokes
probably aren't as good as he'd like to think
they are.
Still, the most important thing to them is
"teaching their memory-challenged daughter
how to survive."
Loons replace the seagulls from Finding Nemo,
and in Finding Dory we meet Becky, an offbeat,
kooky loon who takes a shine to Marlin, and
although Nemo is sceptical about her, she's
probably cleverer than she looks.
The returning cast include Dory, Nemo and
Marlin of course!
In Finding Dory, Nemo has gone back to school
after his big adventure in Finding Nemo, and
is the first to offer his help to Dory when
she decides to embark on her ocean search
for her family.
Nemo's father Marlin is more hesitant about
jumping in with Dory's mission to head to
the California coast, but he understands what
it's like to lose family, and Dory of course
helped him to find Nemo.
The spotted-eagle-ray teacher, Mr Ray, will
be back, and this time Dory will be his perky
teacher's assistant during his student field
trips around the coral reef and seabed.
The cool ocean turtles Crush and his son Squirt
return again happy to "lend a flipper to a
fish in need."
And the Tank Gang who escaped from the dentist's
office at the end of Finding Nemo will also
be back for the sequel.
Expected to return are the Moorish Idol fish,
Gill, and Deb, the blue and white damselfish
who believed her reflection in the fish tank
was her sister Flo.
And many fellow Pixar fans are hoping that
we'll see the French shrimp Jacques from the
dentist's office make a comeback too.
Sadly, the original voice actor Joe Ranft
died between the making of the two films,
but it's hoped that his brother Jerome may
step in to the role.
John Ratzenberger is rumoured to cameo again
in Finding Dory as the voice of the school
of Moonfish who appeared in Finding Nemo.
And finally, there will be sea otters in Finding
Dory, lots of cute, adorable otters!
So guys, who's your favourite character from
Finding Nemo?
And how excited are you for the sequel?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you love Pixar and animation, you might
also like my Pixar easter egg videos, 25 fun
facts about Zootopia and 27 awesome facts
about Kung Fu Panda 3!
Click on any of these here to check those
videos out.
And if you enjoyed this do hit that subscribe
button for more videos like this!
Thanks for watching.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!